bonjour à tous je suis stéphanie martens
j'ai 27 ans et je suis l'heureuse maman
de deux petits garçons je suis aussi la
fille d'une femme qui a passé sa vie à
se sacrifier pour les autres
petites moi j'entendais souvent ma mère
me dire qu'elle rêvait d'avoir un salon
t vous savez ce salon t on peut venir
échanger discuter boire du café et
manger de bonnes pâtisseries oui mais
voilà ce rêve est toujours resté au fond
de sa poche parce que elle a toujours ma
mère a toujours fait passer les autres
avant elle
pourquoi est-ce que je viens d'une
famille ouvrière avec une mentalité
plutôt machiste où la femme elle doit
être petit gentil et dévoué aux autres
alors dévoué notamment à son mari
surtout quand il est malade et à ses
enfants
donc du coup moi je grandis avec ce
schéma familial où la femme doit mettre
ses rêves de côté
déjà moins à l'époque je voulais être
psychologue j'étais passionné par
l'humain et la psychologie et j'avais
dit à ma famille je vais être
psychologue sauf qu'on m'a répondu ah
laisse tomber ça c'est une voie de
garage tu en feras rien du tout ok bon
visiblement ils s'étaient pas
visionnaire du tout ce qui se passe
actuellement je ris beaucoup de taf mais
bon à l'époque j'avais pas confiance en
moi et j'ai décidé de les écouter donc
je me suis dirigé vers une filière
d'assistante sociale même si ce n'était
pas vraiment mon diplôme de coeur
j'étais quand même je restais quand même
dans l'humain donc j'ai eu mon diplôme
ensuite mon premier travail et la même
année je suis tombée enceinte de mon
premier garçon j'ai acheté ma maison
donc moi au début j'avais l'impression
d'avoir réussi ma vie d'avoir l'avis de
cliff et d'avoir tout surtaxé
mais sauf que voilà quelques années plus
tard on passait et j'ai commencé à me
poser votre coûte beaucoup de questions
j'étais pas pleinement épanouie j'avais
plus de plaisir j'ai pu le voir dans mon
coeur à tel point que j'avais même plus
d'énergie j'arrivais le week-end j'avais
qu'une envie c'était de faire la sieste
alors avant de trois ans ça la fout mal
quand même
donc du coup j'ai commencé à me poser
beaucoup de questions en fait qui je
suis moi qu'est ce que j'ai envie
j'ai donc pris le jeu j'ai fait le choix
de consulter de consulter un thérapeute
et j'ai pris conscience que toutes ces
années là
j'avais répondu à toutes les injonctions
de la société j'avais été la bonne
petite fille dont tout le monde
attendait sauf que j'avais rien fait
pour moi et donc en sortant de ce procès
cette thérapie je me suis acheté un
cahier donc c'est ce cahier était
magnifique il était jaune je l'assimilé
à la joie donc j'ai pris ce cahier et je
me suis dit que j'allais écrire mes
rêves qu'est-ce qui est ce que j'avais
envie de réaliser dans ma vie alors
toute contente j'achète mon carnet donc
je l'ouvré je me dis mais en fait je
sais ce que je veux pas mais je sais
absolument pas ce que je veux
donc je commence à partir en
introspection dans la recherche je lis
beaucoup je lis beaucoup de livres de
psychologie
je découvre la neuroscience la physique
quantique en bref je découvre plein de
plein de thématiques et je me rends
compte que je suis toujours passionné
par l'humain que j'ai envie de reprendre
mes études je découvre aussi
l'entrepreneuriat le mindset etc je
commence à écrire que j'ai envie d'être
entrepreneuse que j'ai envie de
reprendre mes études en psychologie en
coaching j'ai aussi envie surtout de
faire des conférences tedx ça c'était
l'un de mes rêves et je commence à
écrire tout ça donc je retrouve plein
d'énergie je me dis waouh c'est trop
bien j'ai envie de réaliser tout ça
sauf que
non
arrivé à l'âge non pardon à la naissance
de mon deuxième enfant liam il ya deux
ans en pleine crise sanitaire je me
rends compte que j'ai tous ces projets
en tête mais je n'en ai réalisé aucun
avec cette crise sanitaire je prends
conscience que la vie est bien trop
courte et que demain je ne sais pas de
quoi sera le feu la vie et je décide de
prendre mon courage à deux mains être
quitté mon travail pour reprendre mes
études
sauf que j'avais pas prévu ce qui va se
passer
alors que je suis en pleine évolution
j'ai en train de chercher ma première
formation j'ai mon conjoint de l'époque
qui m'annonce tu sais cette stéphanie là
elle me plaît pas je te pose un
ultimatum t'arrête tout ça et tu
redeviens comme avant où soit on peut
pas continuer comme ça
bon bah là c'est le couperet qui tombe
parce que cette stéphanie l'ain moi elle
me plaît c'est stéphanie là c'est la
vraie c'est celle qui a envie
d'entreprendre est partagée avec avec
son coeur je décide alors de prendre une
grande décision de quitter aussi mon
conjoint de l'époque
mais j'avais pas prévu de vivre une
séparation chaotique
le 20 février 2021 je me retrouve devant
chez moi et une dispute et clu éclate
avec mon ex mari alors je vous épargne
les détails mais elle a été d'une
violence sans nom
les mots qu'il a prononcés
je ne fera rien de ta vie tu n'es qu'une
merde
ont été l'élément déclencheur
de ma vie
alors j'ai pris mes enfants sous le bras
je partis sans rien à part des vêtements
c'était pas mal quand même je partirai
que mes vêtements j'ai laissé la maison
je suis parti en urgence chez mes
parents alors ça faisait vraiment chier
un ace que se retrouver sept ans après
chez ses parents avec deux enfants sous
le bras c'était pas terrible donc j'ai
plutôt envie d'être libre et j'ai donc
décidé de faire coûte que coûte de
trouver un appartement alors trouver un
appartement quand on n'a plus de travail
qu'on est mère célibataire avec deux
enfants en bas âge accrochez vous bien
bon c'est pas grave j'ai rien lâché j'ai
quand même trouvé mon appartement et je
me suis dit que j'allais pas arrêté
j'allais pas m'arrêter là j'ai donc
quand même décidé de l'inscrire ma
formation j'ai été prise du premier coup
sauf que j'avais pas prévu que cette
formation ne soit pas financée par pôle
emploi et là encore quelque chose qui me
tombe sur la tête et j'ai mon collègue
de l'époque qui me dit écoute stéphanie
moi je vais t'aider je vais
t'accompagner pour te financer cette
formation
donc je repars sur les chemins de
l'école j'obtiens mon diplôme
en septembre devine adelin 21 et je me
dis en sortant de cette formation c'est
cool j'ai le diplôme mais moi j'ai envie
d'ouvrir ma boîte et comment on fait je
viens d'un milieu ouvrier où le mot
entrepreneuriat ça fait peur c'est
synonyme de danger donc je me dis je
vais pas m'engager pas m'arrêter là et
je vais prendre une coach business pour
m'accompagner justement dans cette
évolution mais j'avais pas prévu que
pôle emploi viendrait encore m'embêter
parce qu à ce moment là le moment je
décide d'investir de l'argent pôle
emploi meurent à 10 par erreur et là
j'ai encore la chance d'avoir mon
collègue qui qui croient en moi et en
mes projets et qui m'accompagne encore
dans le financement de cette mon
coaching et à la suite de ce coaching
j'ouvre mon entreprise
et est vraiment j'aimerais vous dire que
comment on fait pour passer du rêve à la
réalité parce que moi ça me semblait
tellement loin ce que je suis en train
de vivre aujourd'hui ne serait-ce que
d'être ici parmi vous réaliser ce rêve
de tedx ça me semblait tellement loin
aujourd'hui je vous parle elle partagée
par dont les cinq ingrédients que j'ai
utilisée pour passer du rêve à la
réalité
alors premier ingrédient
je me suis posé la question du pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui aujourd'hui me donne de
l'énergie qu'est ce qui m'anime qu'est
ce qui me motive dans ma vie parce que
vous doutez bien avec toutes les galères
que j'ai traversés si j'avais pas eu un
pourquoi ce pourquoi d'inspirer les
autres et de d'entreprendre mais je me
serais arrêté au premier obstacle donc
aujourd'hui vraiment je vous invite à
vous poser la question qu'est ce qui
vous donne de l'énergie pourquoi vous
avez envie d'être enfin quelle est votre
mission vraiment c'est hyper hyper
important
deuxième ingrédient
mettez vous un plan d'action
moi j'entends souvent des personnes ne
dira un jour je réaliserai mes rêves bon
un jour égale jamais alors posez vous la
question par exemple dans 1 ans 5 ans 10
ans ou est ce que j'ai envie d'être
je vous donne un exemple moi il ya
quatre ans je rêvais de faire un thé
dicks parmi vous et j'ai promis à mon
fils que pour son sixième anniversaire
je réalise ray mon premier tedx alors
faut savoir que mon fils aura que six
ans dans quelques jours je m'étais fixé
cet objectif parce que je suis une
grande introverti parler en public
c'était les matières peur mais j'ai
décidé comme d'affronter cette peur est
de sortir de ma zone de confort comment
j'ai fait pour réaliser cet objectif
quand on m'a proposé montée de x j'ai
décidé de m'entourer de mentor parce que
oui c'est bien beau je veux faire un
tedx mais je sais pas comment ça marche
et j'ai donc décidé de prendre un coach
pour m'accompagner dans la prise de
parole en public donc vraiment je vous
invite quand vous avez des rêves avoir
un plan et a détaillé ce plan et des
objectifs ces objectifs doivent être
précis atteignable et ambitieux
effectivement si l'année mais de 80
piges kindy quelle envie d'être
chirurgienne bon ça risque d'être
compliqué donc vraiment voilà détaillé
tout ça sur un petit carnet par exemple
troisième élément et pas des moindres
passer à l'action
john a beaucoup qui écrivent leurs rêves
leurs projets mais qui passent jamais à
l'action qui ont peur de l'inconnu peur
d'échouer peur de ne pas réussir comme
disait nelson mandela soit j'apprends
soit je gagne et la meilleure façon de
dépasser sa peur c'est de passer à
l'action
alors oui forcément il y aura des
moments de galère ça sera pas parfait
mais c'est ok parce que c'est dans ces
moments là que vous allez apprendre un
enfant n'a pas appris à marcher du
premier coup mais ba parti à
l'exploration
ensuite quatrième élément
penser positif
ça peut paraître un peu
on a faim il faut savoir qu'on à 60 me
pensé par jour dont
48 mille sont négatives donc c'est un
vrai film d'horreur mentale dans la tête
si on prend pas la décision de reprendre
le contrôle sur son cerveau on peut
vraiment vivre une vie ta terrible et
moi ce que j'ai commencé à faire parce
qu'il faut savoir que j'étais quelqu'un
de très anxieuse et qui voyait le
négatif partout j'ai décidé de pratiquer
la gratitude
la gratitude qu'est ce que
c'est le fait d'avoir de la
reconnaissance pour ce que l'on a dans
sa vie je vous donne un exemple moi tous
les soirs dans mon petit carnet j'écris
pourquoi j'ai de la reconnaissance par
exemple ce soir vous serez dans mon
carnet merci d'être d'être avec toi mimo
enfin merci mlle soit permis de vous
sursautez dicks merci d'avoir le soutien
de ma famille parce que j'ai reçu
beaucoup de messages merci à mon
entourage à mon amour mon conjoint
actuel qui m'a permis de venir ici
aujourd'hui voilà c'est vraiment
commencé à cultiver le positif dans
votre vie parce que le positif à tirer
le positif
est ensuite 5e ingrédients ayez un
entourage
positif
nous sommes la moyenne des cinq
personnes que l'on fréquente le plus
alors une fleur pour qu'elle ait clos du
fonds en botero il faut de l'eau du
soleil est bas dans la vraie vie c'est
pareil si vous avez un terreau merdique
bas autant vous dire que ba pourrait pas
éclore donc vraiment entourez vous de
personnes positives qui croient et
entourez vous également de mentor de
personnes qui ont déjà réussi et qui
sont là où vous voulez être par exemple
quand j'ai décidé d'ouvrir mon
entreprise j'ai pris une coach qui était
déjà qu'ils étaient déjà renommé je me
suis dit je vais je veux m'entourer des
meilleurs pour avoir toutes les
stratégies donc entouré vraiment des
personnes qui ont déjà réussi
et pour clôturer cette conférence
j'aimerais vous donner cette citation
qui me tient à coeur celle de walt
disney
si tu peux le rêver tu peux le faire
merci
[Applaudissements]